mysteries made completely non-mysterious
romances i barely saw the light of day
and glaring continuity errors that
permanently harmed a multi-billion
dollar franchise's reputation these are
just a few of the problems left over by
the one harry potter scene fans wish was
never filmed
many story lines in the harry potter
films were embellished such as the final
battle between harry and lord voldemort
other storylines seem to have just
disappeared completely such decisions
can be expected from a law-heavy book
series where each installment's
adaptation needs to fit a two-hour
window even so not all changes will be
appreciated by viewers one particular
scene from the sixth installment is
still remembered as one of the strangest
changes in the film series
with harry potter and the half blood
prince clocking in at over 600 pages
it's no surprise the creators made some
changes when adapting it for the screen
however there was one scene added to the
film that rubbed fans on reddit the
wrong way while harry is celebrating
christmas with the weasleys a group of
death eaters to send upon the family
home and set it ablaze many fans hated
this particular inclusion because it was
never mentioned in the book
one reddit user summed the issue up
substantially saying
it's one thing to say that it's an
adaptation of a large book to a short
movie there has to be cuts this is true
but to write a scene that makes no sense
messes with continuity and is also not
in the books really wrecks that argument
in addition to the scene not being in
the book fans took issue with its lack
of stakes though it was a terrifying
moment for harry and the weasleys it had
no impact on the rest of the series
another redditor pointed out that the
very next scene shows harry and hermione
back at hogwarts completely undeterred
by the fact that their best friend's
childhood home had just been destroyed
in fact this detail remains unmentioned
for the entire rest of the series what's
more the borough is shown fully intact
in the following film the redditch user
went on to criticize the fact that while
it was plausible the weasley family
could have repaired the house using
magic such an easy solution would render
the house's destruction in the first
place completely pointless the borough
was one of the only places that ever
truly felt like home for harry and
without any lasting repercussions within
the story the attack seems like it was
only added for flair additionally the
precious time spent on the fire also
took away from other scenes that were
needed for the film to feel satisfying
for example the only explanation for the
identity of the mysterious half-blood
prince a point so essential to the plot
it made it to the title of the book and
film installments occurs at the end when
professor snape played by alan rickman
announces it with little preamble
yes
i'm
the half blood prince
in the book the identity of the
half-blood prince holds more emotional
weight and gives context to who snape is
as a person yet it has little
consequence in the film another critique
offered by redditors was that there
should have been more time devoted to
the conversations harry and dumbledore
have about voldemort's background
additionally the inclusion of these
scenes would have made the ending of the
film more impactful without establishing
the relationship between the two
characters and showing how much time
they spent together dumbledore's death
and harry leaving school don't pack the
same punch that they should have
unfortunately this isn't the only
on-screen relationship that was cut
short perhaps the most egregious
oversight in half-blood prince was a
lack of screen time devoted to the
depiction of romantic relationships
ron and hermione take up much of the
romantic drama during the film and even
their storyline was still only a shadow
of its depiction in the book since there
was not enough time to explore the
interplay between characters a lot of
individual character development and
particular emotional beats were left on
the cutting room floor entertainment
weekly was especially critical of the
film for its treatment of bonnie
wright's character ginny in the book she
is portrayed as fierce loyal and
confident but the film reduces her to a
one note love interest with minimal
screen time book ginny doesn't wait
around for harry to make the first move
and she's startlingly accomplished to
texas her film portrayal however is one
of the adaptation's worst casualties
despite harry's affection for her she's
portrayed almost as a non-character who
was barely even shown in the film
while it's safe to say not every
slighted character or plot point could
have been put back in the movie if the
borough attack hadn't been added it's no
surprise that fans are wondering why the
scene was even filmed at all
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
harry potter are coming soon subscribe
to our youtube channel and hit the bell
so you don't miss a single one
you